lost at sea
right good afternoon uh councillors
staff members of the public welcome
along to this meeting of the performance
policy and uh partnerships committee the
live stream has begun so just a reminder
got a cell phone on vibrate it's going
to go straight through the table it's a
good idea to tuck it into your pocket
um
we have no apologies but i should note
that council is abbott crackit and
arnold are all in attendance via zoom
uh
no apologies that i'm aware of
it counters for everybody may i at this
stage offer a formal welcome to our two
mana fener representatives to the
performance policy and partnerships
committee meeting
you'll have noted that we've included
your names on the cover sheet of the
agenda
is an expression of the true love that
was promised uh thank you and we
certainly look forward to uh to your
contribution over the meetings to come
uh
first item is the report from the
invercargill youth council and we've got
brooke and tiffany if you want to come
up and take a seat
welcome along um we've had a chance to
have a look at the report it's we're
getting near to the uh the end of the
year
uh for you guys
um so uh it's over to you
um good afternoon councillor i'm tiffany
fan from south and girls high school and
i'm in the overs in youth council hi i'm
bryan ogilvie and i'm also from grass
high and i'm also in the overs so um
obviously our youth council year is
coming to an end and
at our last meeting so we've got one
more meeting after the last and um
last meeting we agreed to adopt the
current terms of reference for 2022 with
no changes we have appreciated having a
counsellor at every meeting as this has
been quite valuable
at our recent meeting we had courtney
brown attend as a speaker from active
southland we were engaged with
her and questions
sorry and we're engaged and asked lots
of questions and
we're keen on making a committee next
year
to get the obviously community involved
with being more active and for our
end-of-year event we
decided to go bowling and have a meal at
koji
yeah and um recently we've been made
aware of the te reo maori strategy and
we're very positive about this and we'll
be looking at adopting the final version
next year and possibly also implementing
some targets
and um
recently we've also been made aware of
the youth mp coming up next year and
fortunately four of our members are
looking to run as a candidate and
another four are looking to sit on a
panel to assist with the labour party
candidates alongside dr liz craig
youth mps will be allowed to go to
wellington and sit in parliament for a
day in june and the youth council
applications are open as we're coming to
the end of the year and the new and
returning members
are welcome to join again and we're
looking for young people living in
invercargill
between the ages of 12 and 24.
we're expecting half of the membership
will be made of of school nominees and
the other half from
community applicants
we're also excited to announce that the
un youth declare declaration documents
has been released and
is available on the icc website on the
youth council page
and that's everything
and is any questions
counselors there are none it's been a
busy year for you and again the the
youth council this year much like last
year has had to uh pivot
uh and have a few meetings online which
is uh interrupted things but we
certainly appreciate the perspective um
that you
that you bring in your reports to us and
also the opportunity that councillor
crackit and i have to
to interact uh with you um i think
you've
been a credit this year it's been really
enjoyable councillor craic has been
involved for a few years preceding this
you might have some comment alex
um yeah i share the same sentiment um
it's always a privilege getting to sit
alongside and participate in
the youth democracy and
honestly the things that youth council
come up with and the things that they're
really passionate about i can bring to
this table
and i just i really value it so thank
you very much guys for participating
this year
um hopefully see you next year
want to move the recommendation alex
absolutely
second thank you councillor sopa
if there are no further questions or
comments for the youth councillors
councillor lewis my apologies must also
come in the youth council for having two
very uh active members on on the
creative communities committee their
input has been variable thank you thank
you just a reminder councillor get that
mic in nice and close
for everybody on zoom
thank you if there are no other comments
or questions it's been moved in second
it'll put the motion all in favor
against carried brook and tiffany you've
given up time during the holidays and
valuable study time no doubt as well
thank you very much for coming along
this afternoon we appreciate it cool
thank you for having us
councillors the next item
is the infocargo representation review
hearings and uh deliberations we've got
the report from uh
from michael and rhiannon we've got a uh
submitter to here very shortly
either of the staff wish to
kick off with with a couple of comments
michael
all right
good afternoon councillors
um sorry just a quick introduction just
to remind everybody where we're at with
this representation review
um
we have are now in the very final stages
we've had the submission stage from the
public after your initial proposal has
gone out uh your deliberation today will
make a recommendation to council to
adopt a final proposal
um
so
this is a the hearing stage uh we have
the one submitter who wish to speak to
you um just to remind everybody her
submission is on page 43 of the
meeting agenda so you can find it and
i'm sure everybody is well aware of the
hearing process so i won't repeat that
and without too much further ado i'll
hand it over to the submitter thank you
just before that counselor clark yes
just through your chair just to um
ensure there's no conflict of interest
both tim and i who is the presenter are
in the invocable ratepayers group uh but
i'm not involved with his submission
today
thank you
i will declare
a vague interest
mr mulligan is a family member
family member of mine
have you had any discussions around no
we have not then you are fine thank you
thanks
tim welcome along please come and uh
take a say if you want to actually if
you want to pop up to this chair here
we've got a safer one
actually one it's easier for you to be
seen it
just a reminder uh councillors as mr
morris said mr mulligan's review is on
page 43 of board books
your time is yours your worship
counsellors now i'm a little bit
unfamiliar with the process so i'm going
to read my submission and then put the
bones on it if you like in righto
i'm astounded that the invercargill city
council has invited consultation from
the public
on a number of on the number of
councillors wards and community boards
etc but there was no public consultation
on the two maori representatives
it is my opinion that people of married
ascent have the same opportunity to
stand for council
as any other aspiring candidate
i also think that this new pro process
shortchanges some of the democratic
system
other aspiring councillors put their
names forward
generally with a short bio stating what
they stand for and what they believe in
etc
by and large they are also required to
front up at pre-election meetings and be
asked to answer questions from the
boating public on what their policies
and principles are
that's the first part with regard to
commenting on the number of councillors
given that we're going ahead with the
two maori councillors
i think there should be only ten other
councillors
the bluff community to stand as it is
as an odata resident i think we're
closely enough aligned with the city not
to require a community board
right
now
up until the substantial change on how
our 12 councillors plus two arrived at
the same conditions for either seeking
election to the council or voting on
elected members has been the same for
all citizens
now there is a second avenue for a group
to gain seats at the table
under our present system the mayor and
elected council is essentially are
essentially up
for a performance review every three
years
if people haven't been happy with their
contribution
then more than likely they're not going
to get a vote on
for the next term
what are the performance
sort of review
um
policies around the two appointed seats
that's the question i'm just leaving
openly
the reason for suggesting in my
submission that we should cap the number
of council seats to 12
and that is 10 elected seats
and
the two appointees
is i think
i think it's hard
to get consensus from 12 people people
plus them here i think it's difficulty
hard it almost
accelerates exponentially when you can't
start increasing the numbers i think 14
makes it
more difficult to arrive at consensus on
things
and if
under this process
if more non-elected people are able to
be promoted to council through
um
non-elected seats appointments then i
don't know we could end up with 14 or 16
seats possibly in the council in a very
short time
i also think that
if we keep the current seats to 10
councillors might value their seats a
bit more they might be a bit less prone
to
tampering with democracy as it stands
further concern might be a bit
but wants to stop other special special
interest groups demanding a seat at the
table like we've got
groups like the ilt here who
significant in town
big footprint and they might say we'd
like
an appointment somebody like scott
o'donnell who's
put a great deal of effort and probably
finances into town over the last few
years might
like a seat at the table
where do we go
yeah i wouldn't mind asking the councils
like it's required seven or more
to take this vote without
consultation i wouldn't mind asking any
of them why they thought that was
appropriate without some sort of
consultation
it's sort of
i think it undermines a lot of people's
democracy
there are regarding i made a comment on
three waters
and i would truly like to think that by
the time
this comes for consideration
councillors feel an absolute obligation
to invite consultation from the
community
before any discussions on the proposed
legislation are made
that's the extent of my submission
thank you mr mulligan uh over to
councillors if you have any questions
bearing in mind the questions not
comments at this point i have some
comments but i'll wait until we get into
the debating of submissions right
are there any questions counselor sopa
thank you mr chair i just wanted to ask
mr mulligan if he was aware of the
partnership principles of tetoriti or
waitangi
not particularly no
thank you mr mulligan
any other questions
yes mr chair your worship
the um
special treatment is being
is it a question or a comment because
we're going to get into the comments
shortly
you will have an opportunity so i'm just
sticking to questions at this point
any other counselors on zoom have any
questions for mr mulligan
nope
no others
thank you sir we do appreciate you uh
taking the time to come along this
afternoon and for making a submission
thank you thank you
councillors that brings us uh back to
the recommendations but before we get to
the recommendations um
councillor amundsen
you've
led this process uh have you any comment
you'd like to make
thank you mr chair
uh yes it's great to be at this point of
the representation review where we've
had
the review out for submissions with the
public and great actually to have so
many submissions come in i think just
over 30
which is really good to get that
feedback
and i would note that most of the
feedback does
support
the three areas that we have identified
in the report which is that we remain
with 12 councillors and amir that we are
elected at large
and across the city rather than through
award system and that we retain the
bluff community board
with its three members and one appointed
councillor
and with the same existing boundaries
so yeah i just would like to extend my
thanks to all the people who have taken
the time to submit we don't always get
submissions in support of the things
that we um put out and it is always good
to get people who do
submit and support not just people who
submit against think again the community
panel who did a really great job of
canvassing the community
before all of this report came together
and of course a big thanks to michael
for all of his work and making sure that
it all came together and was all done on
time so that we didn't miss any of our
um
our deadlines
and um
i guess i just wanted to make a comment
around
the manafinoa seats whilst they weren't
exactly part of the representation
review
there was some
engagement around that as part of that
process and i guess really the important
thing to me is that um the local
government act gives us a mandate to
make such appointments and that is why
we have done it and um as councillor
sopa alluded to it is part of our
obligations under the treaty of waitangi
as well so thank you i'm happy to move
the recommendations
thank you councillor emerson
to second those mr chair
hey open for comment councillor partner
now thank you mr chair um look i've got
a question that is um
concerns representation review but i
don't think it it's covered under our
bit but it's more
covered under
local government review or something
like that and through the chair i'd like
to direct the question at michael
it's regarding
how
with
something like the regional council you
have the group of elected members
selecting a chair with territorial
territorial authorities
we have a mayor contested for a separate
spot and then you have the elected
members contestant the reason i raised
that is that
look the go the local government act is
quite specific on the role of amir
it sees quite clearly
41a
section two it is the role of the mayor
to lead the development of the
territorial authorities plans including
the long-term plan the annual plan
policies and budgets for consideration
by members
et cetera it's quite a it's it's a job
description and this is statutory law
it's not like it's an optional thing to
do and i'm just wondering taking that
into account when you look at the bigger
picture
the election of a new mayor
is
there is no
interview
by the board or whatever
you get the role you could be
a brand new person never done local
government before and yet
you are expected to do that under law
jump straight in whereas with the
regional council health boards
they
the group of members would choose the
most the person most capable
uh democratically and i'm just wondering
is this something that would be done
obviously not under representation
review but i believe this got changed
around in 1989
and maybe
the local government review would
potentially look
at this representation
through you mr chair
i think this is on hopefully
um
the short answer is yes it is would be
within the province of the local
government with you uh you are quite
correct the position i mean
the possession of regional councils were
established in 1989
and they
were decided that they could elect their
chair from amongst their members whereas
the position of mayor is of course a
very old position and it's essentially a
hangover from what came
from the uk uh during the colonization
process
and has remained in statute ever since
uh it is something that i suspect when
you're looking at all of the functions
of territory authorities and council and
their local government review it as
something that will need to be
considered as part of that
thank you thanks
thank you
i guess the comment i'd like to make is
it
would be easy through the process to
have confused
the consultation that we were doing
around
uh maori wards and the representation
review because they were actually two
separate pieces of consultation
uh one was with the wider community one
was with ewy specifically
but because they were being done at the
same time
i understand how it's easy for several
of the submitters to
have confused the issue
they are separate and it's provided for
in the local government act i i wouldn't
describe uh our
ewe as interest groups
there is a partnership that exists
between uh
maori and the crown
which is a couple of steps above where
we're at and that's where this becomes
an option
and in consultation with uh both
they both very clearly said that the
option to have representation on the
council committees was of more value to
them than than a modern ward and so
uh amana fenu representatives sit on our
committees not on on council and around
the question that was raised around
review well that's up to aodor and
wahhabi each time they they make their
appointments they decide whether or not
the representatives they've had on this
committee and infrastructural services
have have done a good job
not our business
but i again
think it was uh useful to go through the
process the involvement that we had from
from members of the public was
um good and not only coming forward but
also nominating themselves to to be on
the panel as well so tell me you had a
comment you wanted to make
yes just that there are special
occasions where
it is this assists the bigger group
over any community and making decisions
like this
and one of it is covered
why is this separate
strength given to
october
and
it's
those areas where amir can be an
advocate for
the region
and that would be spelt out in there as
well
so there are advantages to both
communities
by having i think a positive approach
to
this issue
thank you so tim
um michael can i just ask a question
that
uh recommendation 4 is requesting a
final proposal be brought to council
wednesday coming forward is that the
next council meeting that would be
correct yes thank you councillor clare
thank you chair um
and in light of the position i've
previously previously taken i just want
to express my opposition to the two
appointed positions that's no reflection
on the people that have been appointed i
want to be quite clear on that
the local government act from my reading
does not allow appointments to full
council and i believe the
ethos or the understanding of that is
that the decision-making of any council
needs to be with elected members and
elected members only
and the local government act does allow
for appointees to committees
and it does also suggest that we need to
engage with monophenol and i don't
have any opposition to that what's
unique to this council is we have
delegated our decision making to those
committees and in my view in light of
that we should not have appointments on
the committees
that um
that have
a voting right that's not through an
elected process
so i just want to continue to have that
opposition thank you
noted counselor soap
thank you mr chair um i wasn't going to
comment but
for the members of the public listening
on zoom i think it has to be made clear
that there are by statute certain
decisions that cannot be delegated
from council to its committees and in
vicar i will not try and
summarize all those at this time but i
will point out that invicago has not
delegated all decisions to committees
because there are some by statute that
can only be made by council
i would not like anybody
who is listening to us on zoom
be left with the incorrect impression
that we have somehow
given full voting council
privileges
when that is not in fact the case we
have appointed as per the partnership
principles to our committees in my
opinion quite rightly to manafenua
representatives of very high quality
we have not delegated all council
decisions to those committees thank you
mr chair thank you i think it's also
worth noting that there are similar
delegations uh
to the committees in wellington city
where there are also uh manafenoua
representatives as well
councillor clark yeah but just a pointer
order on that chair um
i
need to challenge the incorrect
impression that my colleague has alluded
to
i didn't suggest at all
and being delegated i do appreciate that
there are some statutory delegations
that we retain at full council and we
also retain the issues
involve the chief executive's employment
but in re in realistic terms probably 95
or 99 of what we deal with on a
day-by-day week by week basis is now
delegated to those two committees so
people that are listening and need to
understand that thank you
thank you again we're starting to cloud
the issue around the representation
review so
i'll bring the discussion back to that
so we've got the four recommendations
the
suggestion is ultimately that the final
proposal taking into account the
feedback from councillors comes to the
next full meeting
of council
four recommendations have been moved and
seconded are there any more questions or
comments
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
kerry
sorry on my post
screen oh my please did you like your
vote recorded thank you thank you
item six we've got the minutes of the
community well-being fund uh committee
meeting councillor lewis i'd like to
move those be accepted
mr chair i can second that and and doing
so also i'd like to thank the staff for
all the extra work they do behind the
scenes thank you very much
thank you
it's been moved in second if there are
any questions or comments now is the
time
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
we've got the minutes of uh the last ppp
meeting uh back on september 14th which
we had most of us over zoom
uh would somebody like to move their
true and correct record councillor
and counselor partner
any questions
counselor abbott did you have a question
or are you just resting ahead
you're really gonna have to sort out a
microphone uh counselor
oh you were trying to move it
yeah okay
thank you
your mic level on that computer is
really light
thanks
uh it's been moved in second it'll put
the motion all in favor all right
against
carried
uh item eight was uh originally coming
to this committee which was um
around the the manafenua ros and uh we
were expecting a report around
honorarium uh claire do you want to
discuss that we could um yes mr chair i
would um advise the committee that
michael morris and i met with uh
representatives from the two roonaka
last week
and after
engaging with them i offered that it
would be possible for this committee to
hand back
its delegation for this item only to
counsel for council to consider it at
its meeting at the end of the month
and they have so asked so i would ask
the committee
um resolve to do
to do that
i'm happy to move that yes and
councillors over
it's open for discussion
that's the time that it'll take that's
the time it'll take i'll put the motion
all in favor
against
carried
time for some name calling uh brings us
on to item nine
michael i see you have a microphone
that's very handy
yes thank you council um
we've got two
two reports um under
nine and ten on your report which are
both naming naming rights to roads uh
the first the first one is for sunrise
drive 4600 drive and the name that's
been put forward there is glenda place
that's consistent current with the
current policy
um
[Music]
as per the
terms laid out in the
report the second one
um
through yourself the chair if it's okay
to do both together yes absolutely uh
the the second report which is
raunch
sorry wrench hunt um street is um also
there but there is the name there is
morningside
i'll just keep the confirm morningside
lane
and that again is compliant with the
current policy in relation to the naming
of
roads
thank you so they both meet with uh
what's in the bounds of the policy
and they're both being agreed to by
developers
i'm happy to take the two together if
somebody wants to move the two
recommendations councillor pottinger
councillor clark
open councillor amazon
i just wonder about the actual policy
itself
if i can be so bold as to ask be bold um
how many decades ago was the policy put
in place
two
um
quite simple really too i remember it
wow okay
it just seems um because we've done a
few
names of streets in the last few ppp
meetings
and they're all
um
very european names
and i wonder actually whether
um there's anything that we can
do to the policy to
make it a little bit more
modern
when does the policy come up for revere
michael
maybe two decades no you can review it
at any stage
for yourself the chair the policy hasn't
been reviewed in some time we could
actually um through council
um
instigator review we are
at the option of doing a policy review
at the moment oh thank you pania
um yeah i had this similar question
because i was actually the question is
is there a reason why we don't reflect
our maori heritage by using a koopa
maori
type name or is it are we always going
to be reflecting
our scottish heritage and our
other heritage so at the moment if i can
proceed the policy seeks
suggestions from the developers but i
guess a review of the policy could put
forward or give more prominence to some
of the other options that are available
so as a separate process i think it
would be good it's sufficient for us to
signal that we would appreciate a paper
coming forward
rihanna
um just to clarify chair if it's helpful
that the current approach follows the
generic industry guidelines there is no
formal policy as such except to follow
those guidelines so it would be a case
of introducing a policy which is
um potentially what um council might
like to request i think that sounds good
i must obviously remember when we
adopted the guidelines
it felt like a policy but it's like
stepping on a piece of lego
it feels a lot bigger than it actually
is
so back to the the two names so um i
think
we can have a paper come forward at a
future ppp meeting and just look at the
formation of a policy but we've got two
suggested names in uh morningside lane
and glenda place
uh
was it we had a mover in a second didn't
we yes we did any further discussion
if not i put the motion all in favor
thank you and noted the the raising of
hands on zoom as well
district plan effectiveness
uh who's taking us through this treaty
no
yes
yes
you've got a microphone
so
kyoto koto
counsellors and your worship uh
i'll take the report as read and
just
it's very simply we are undertaking an
effectiveness
report an update about our district plan
and you'll note that
we may include or we will include a
section that addresses climate change
matters and also
if there is any information that comes
to life where we could make improvements
to the district plan that we may look at
changing making some changes to that
effect
so two questions from me one have you
got a timeline that you're thinking of
uh the team are working to have that an
early
next year to have the first
report back to the committee the
secular's really just
confirming that we wouldn't have to do
an entire review of the district plan we
can just pick out the pieces of it that
we wanted to to change
that is correct my understanding
counselor thanks
councillor pottinger thank you chair
um
an intensification for housing
uh where
around cbd it's been raised um areas
like south city windsor where you're
close to community facilities walking
distance and you really
we don't want to be sprawling obviously
the city doesn't want to be expanding
yet uh the
any plan is quite restrictive into the
size of a section you've got to have x
amount
so we we're going to look at that if we
need to get more dwellings that the
demand and people don't want sections
and they is that something we
we're going to be more permissive with
or look at
look i think it's a broad
a broad approach at this stage but uh i
take on board the feedback and something
that i can get our specialist staff to
address
if you have certain zoning for us
yeah so the short answer is yes you can
um you can do reviews of the district
plan that look at the appropriate zoning
so
uh if you had
more urban style living which is living
without
sections and with
higher
levels of noise
allowed
i think that currently exists within the
cbd but you suggest you know do you take
it out into some of those hubs where
similarly there are those
um retail zones or zones when you can
expect um greater noise in people
wanting to to locate closer to that for
the convenience um certainly you could
do that through this process so i guess
the main question is does is
do we wait for developers to come and
ban bang the door or do we are we to be
more proactive and say hey we're quite
keen for this to happen well this is a
chance for us to review that counsellor
and to make sure that as you see the
broad headings strategic context
so that would fall under that with where
we were sitting
and i think you know bearing in mind
there's um uh national pressure for an
increase in housing it's probably quite
time that we look at that your worship
yes if we're looking at the issue of
crises we've just had a meeting with the
regional council
and looking at flooding at the airport
and all sorts of traumas that could
happen to us
but
i feel that the biggest crisis we're
facing and we'll ever face and it's not
three waters
it's the
[Music]
the levels of death that's going to
happen in our community
as a result of covert
and we've gotta i believe start
preparing for the worst as well as
believing in the future of course
but um
and
what
can we do to prepare ourselves if the
worst does come to the past
thank you worship probably a broader
issue for council and not really a
district plan one but
worthy of no councillor clark yeah just
like to reinforce what rainey had to say
before
we had a submitter about two or three
months ago a developer who raised this
issue about the
ability to intensify within the in the
city
and i i agree i think we should as a
council be looking towards
rules that allow those developers to
to proactively develop what they want
and not be
on the back foot against our rules and i
think if we can i mean i don't say that
be open slather but you just did
well what i'm suggesting is that if you
if you tighten the rules up too much
it's too hard for developers to come
forward and that's what the submission
we had last time which rangy was talking
to that we need to have some ability to
encourage people
to look at alternatives in the standard
plots that we have at the moment
well interestingly um you know one of
the people who came to us recently was
talking about uh tiny houses and
actually the ability for
those types of houses to be erected in
the city already exists and it's it's
quite often a case that will come and
ask but at the same time
maybe we should be looking at promoting
what options there are that are
available councillor amazon did you have
panda yeah i think i did um
so i just note that there's obviously
going to be more than one report coming
that it talks about the main focus of
the report to be produced by the end of
2021
is to be on residential development
subdivisions and natural hazards and i'm
just wondering whether
with all the talk of housing that maybe
rather than just residential development
it could have a broader scope and be
talking about cbd residential
development as well as
um you know suburban development in
those countries residential uh
residential development would include
zoning
residential zoning yeah oh and you know
like what are the barriers for
um residential development in the cbd
and are any of those barriers things to
do with the district plan
okay
um let me move to three recommendations
actually to get the ball rolling
is there a second of that
council of sopa thank you
thanks for the discussion council is
there any other questions or comments
before i put those
so i keep getting distracted by
councillor arnold's head in the sand
[Laughter]
someone has been buried
at the beach there i hope you're all
right ellen
didn't see why i'm so upset
i tired
i'm okay good
i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried thank you for that
nice to hear you counsellor
uh brings us to the community well-being
fund review
brianna and jenna gemma welcome
tena koto katoa no moto pahoy aho core
strategy and policy takumahi called
gemma takuingwa for those of you who
don't know me i am jimmy crawford the
engagement and partnerships officer in
the strategy and policy team here at icc
um i will take the community wellbeing
fund review report as read
the community wellbeing fund committee
recently held a workshop to discuss the
first financial year of the fund and how
it was tracking and whether anything
needed to be reviewed the main points
you can see from the report are one the
option of adding a young person to the
committee
the option of
an additional piece of criteria that
excludes operational costs for health
services
the option of amending the scores for
both economic and livability well-beings
to aid the applications to more closely
align with the purpose of the fund
and please also find um at appendix one
an overall summary of the outcomes from
the first three rounds of the well-being
fund
this highlights which kind of projects
funding went to and gives a clear
picture of the fund distribution in the
first financial year
so council lewis is um the chair of the
community wellbeing fund committee and
he may wish to add anything um to what i
have noted today and i am of course
happy to answer any questions
councillor lewis thank you chian thank
you very much jim everyone and for all
the work you do this 18 page
include the cover sheet report is very
extensive and i think it speaks for
itself
one might look at the grants that we've
made and you look there's 2 000
sorry 288 000 plus
dollars granted but if you
i didn't actually use a calculator but
my calculations of the amounts have been
applied for about 780 000 so there's
quite a lot of work going through that
of the applications to to
rationalize the the
applications and and try to
i don't know
russian the amounts that we have we're
limited to 500 000 per per a year by
financial year it's difficult and i
would like to thank very much
jimmy particularly and rhiannon and the
other staff who are involved with the
all the organization and particularly
the members of the of the committee some
of whom of course are community
representatives and
hence the
result from the steve bramney workshop
which all members attended even by zoom
um that this consideration of a
uh considerations i should say of
payment for all the hours that are
involved on the committee preps which
are in the general review that was
coming up later in the year
but basically chair it's pretty
self-explanatory it's a very good report
and i i thank them everybody yet again
thank you
do you want to uh and i
i'd like to move all
uh recommendations on on their cover
sheet
thank you councillor sarah secretary
councillor ken thank you sorry
marginally better got a better thumbs up
from councillor crackit than you did
from me but
i'll note you as the seconder for that
thank you
thank you
councillor lewis can i ask um what the
feedback is that you've had from the
community representatives from there
taking part in the process
they've been very enthusiastic um but
the enthusiasm hasn't really been taken
into account the fact they attend and
contribute sensibly and wisely i think
is the most important thing
okay
questions or comments
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
against
carried thank you
uh that brings us to the update on the
invocative community community
recreation and sports trust and active
communities grants administration
these pauses for breath after that uh
rhiannon
thank you cha um kiara councillors so
yes this is just an update that was
requested by the committee as to
progress on
this process um so i will just take the
report to asrad and answer any questions
essentially we're just noting the
information that we've been provided
with that's correct thank you
uh i'm happy to move the three
recommendations if there's a second day
yeah
councillor pottinger actually managed to
get his digit up
questions or comments this is the
feedback you were looking for um it has
been helpful so thank you for that
if there's none i'll put the motion all
in favor
against
carried
uh that brings us to the request for
funding for the lakes district and air
uh rescue trust uh this was an item that
was raised by councillor clark there was
um a series of recommendations that came
forward that we were looking for
feedback and and some more information
uh around
uh who's grabbing for the microphone on
this one i see one in steve's hand but
it's really probably more down brienne
there you go
thank you it's me again
don't apologize
um
so again i'll take this report as read
this report is really a follow-up to um
councillor clark's
paper that he brought to the last
committee meeting following the mayoral
forum meeting where um this group
presented
with a request for funding so from that
committee meeting it was requested that
officers go away and bring forward some
options for the committee to consider so
this paper is doing that
um and yeah happy to answer any
questions thank you one of the the
recommendations that we examined last
time was that our support would be
conditional on the other
tas contributing as well
the third recommendation is looking for
clarity as i understand it the other tas
have
not
opted to support it which would leave us
in the same position as that your
understanding counselor clark yes it was
conditional to the other
two councils supporting
so i guess we would need more clarity
around uh recommendation three
um
around the option that we decline
uh
the opportunity to fund bearing in mind
that we were going to
i think
50 30 20 was the split with us and 50
provided the others were at 30 and 20
but they're not
so the recommendation for option three
would be that council declines the
opportunity to fund
based on that
i'm happy to move recommendation one and
two and clarify that option three is
that um we
declined the option to fund
zero seconder
or second council of super ringing
um we're just seeking clarity around
normally
requests like this i've seen in the past
would come to our annual plans
and uh time it with all councils and
their annual plans and
so this the timing to me doesn't quite
seem
right for you know for the amount of
money we're talking here how to factor
it in i think it would get more
i guess more consideration through that
annual plan process
rather than coming in
yeah i guess that the opportunity always
arises and and they'll have the
opportunity to approach council through
the annual plan process again
next year but there will always be
occasionally some organizations that
through various circumstances didn't
have the opportunity to submit then who
who might come forward at some other
point yeah i guess the reason i raised
that with the annual plan thing is that
when you're looking at three councils
doing the annual plan thing is at least
you can get it on the sort of agenda and
some councils are quite strict and
and right we're in there and the rest of
the year
she's quiet yeah we're in lockdown for
three years now
sorry i probably shouldn't use that
i actually understand i mean this is a
really important service
um to our community in some way or form
um
and under option one well it's pretty
obviously that
um it's pretty low scoring so
it's
has you know made a
little benefit there for it
would a contribution rather than 50k be
more acceptable i mean for discussion or
if the current motion on the table fails
yes
councillor abbott and then councillor
arnold
that was the proposal at this point
would you rather i just started with the
first two
three
[Music]
um
quite some time ago rihanna good luck
i can speak counsellor to what it is for
but the question of when it was last
used we would need to seek
guidance from the finance team it is
there for emergency scenarios such as
flooding
yep
but when it was last used i'm afraid i
can't answer now
[Music]
michael
yes thank you through yourself the chair
um yes the last time we've used funds of
this nature is during flooding events
the funds are set aside for emergency
situations
that's the purpose of them but
if it's the council's desire that that
that can be
done in that way but
from a finance perspective the purpose
is fairly clear that they are there for
emergency situations
i agree councillor arnold
uh you always sort of think that it's an
extremely important service and i think
that we should just take a lead on it i
mean if the other councils decide not to
come along i believe that we should
still do it
you can't move anything at the moment
councillor but uh we take your point uh
for number three i think it's something
that we should do and if we can fund it
from a community well-being fund i mean
what better use for the community
well-being fund is there and something
that's a service to everybody and sells
them so just just for your information
councillor the issue was referred to the
community well-being fund and it didn't
actually meet their criteria
really yep well i i
would support funding anyway so
if you're going to separate number three
and do that i'll be probably with the
other ones
thank you again yes thanks
rihanna
just a point of clarification it hasn't
been referred at this point to the
community well-being fund we have scored
the application as if it would be of
course the community well-being fund
committee
do debate every topic so they don't
necessarily always follow exactly the
scoring criteria you could refer it
there but we know obviously
that it may not be successful sorry i
should correct what i said i referred it
to the chair
thank you
uh councillor clark then councillor
soper
councillor scout just a couple of issues
of clarification um i think the last
time the emergency fund was used was
recently to
um resolve
two residents and matera that had not
been able to resolve their flooding
issues so it is probably primarily for
that sort of emergency not for an
emergency service as such
the issue of the 2.5 using the steve
brownlee thing um steve brownlee's
formula is an excellent tool for many
things but it's not a one
fit all type thing i mean a classic
example
if you use the
steve brownlee um formula on anderson's
house you'd never invest any money in it
and because it just doesn't stack up
um but we do invest in and quite heavily
in in henderson's house and the
surrounding gardens so it's not a matter
of just using that formula to say hey
it's 2.5 it's not high enough um i'm
disappointed that the other two councils
haven't contributed given they were the
ones that were driving the conversation
at the mayoral forum
but i still think it's an important
issue to to do
um i think most ratepayers would not
give at something less than two dollars
per year to have it available um it's a
unique service
yeah you don't realize how important it
is until you have a family member or
somebody close here that needs it
um so it's still very much in favor of
making some sort of donation towards the
trust even if the other councils don't
but i accept rangy's point that i think
it's probably an ideal situation where
we might look to our annual plan if we
wanted to solidify a sort of
support on an ongoing basis
councillor sofa
thanks mr chair um i just wanted to make
the point that
one reason i seconded your
alteration to recommendation three
is if your pardon me using the
expression um a concern
about this particular issue having the
potential to open the floodgates
to a lot of ad hoc applications from a
whole host of
bodies and organizations that in
lots of ways may be unique
and have very good stories to tell but
we have worked quite hard as a council
and particularly i refer to setting up
community well being fun with the
criteria it has
to try and
get away from ad hoccary and making
decisions of this type
my concern about any other decision
then what is in the recommendations
today would be that it was
an ad hoc
type decision
we have tried very hard to move away
from that and i think it would open the
floodgates in a way that we also tried
to avoid
the suggestion about the possibility of
approaching it long-term annual plan
time
has some sense to it but again
we have to be careful about the criteria
because we don't again want to open the
floodgates
to everybody turning up for
annual plan every year
and
my memory of community wellbeing fund
was to encourage
some people some organizations that
might have done that at annual plan time
to look at community wellbeing fund is a
more appropriate
fund to approach so
i'm just worried that this sort of
application
out of cycle with no
policy covering it
does have the potential again to open up
a whole host of ad hoc applications that
we
really have tried to
deal with in other ways
thank you councillor scout
i threw your chair just brian i wonder
if you've got um
any explanation from the other two a's
regarding their
um not contributing or making no control
contribution after all it came from the
mural before in which they actually
drove initially the initiative around
this
what was the actual reasoning behind the
decline
so gore have requested that they come
and speak again directly to their
council
gore district council and southern
district council indicated it's a matter
they've discussed a number of times and
that was behind their decision
so they discussed in a matter of times
but the conclusion was
i
don't matter
oh
that's the information that i was given
i certainly wouldn't want to speak on
their behalf
and to counsel
the fact of ad hoc i'm not sure where ad
hoc was brought up four or five months
ago
and in actual effect through the mural
forum it's incredibly short-sighted to
be honest
this is hardly an ad hoc
and it affects everybody so
i find it staggering absolutely
staggering okay actually counselor can i
just caution you because
counselor sofa was talking about the
application processes being hit ad hoc
it certainly wasn't a comment from my
interpretation of devaluing the service
that's offered by the helicopter i
wasn't suggesting that i was saying
the decision of those two tas was
appalling
i'm very happy to validate that
any other questions or comments at the
moment because i will separate out and
take the first two items if not
so recommendations one and two they've
been moved in second and i'll vote take
a vote on those now all in favor
aye against
carrie that brings us to recommendation
three which has been moved and seconded
which is uh that we decline
um
the application
and
as the mover and speaking to that
i also am not
uh devaluing the service um that the
helicopter trust offers
i guess
my concern is because i understand and
know it's worth and have heard it's
worth from many people who've had to
make use of the service to
travel from
southland hospital to dunedin
but there's part of me that goes
the uh one of the other trusts as is
reported in the paper
is funded by the otago regional council
so that way it takes
a regional approach to to funding and
it's a it's a shame
that that approach hasn't been used here
and that the approach could have gone to
environment south and so that way we
haven't got the three councils picking
each other off and going well i will if
you will
um
and and dare i say
in full knowledge that somebody won't
and and there's the out uh so it is a
shame that
in this instance the helicopter trust
didn't make
the application to es with with that
because i think it is more
an issue that covers the wider region
rather than than just invercargill city
so again just reinforcing that while i'm
moving a motion that declines the option
to fund it is not
at all intended as
any form of devaluation of the the value
of the service
open for other comments council of
pottenger
you
live in a
very unusual society where they
where our main ambulance provider that
we take for granted that when we
have an injury or something has to go
out and fundraise and i think any
country looking in from a distance would
have a chuckle to think what
you're serious that the government
doesn't pay
for your ambulances it pays for police
imagine the police fundraising how would
that go
yeah i'm not sure
but it might struggle a bit more to me
yeah yeah yeah or even the you got a
fundraise for your fire trucks you know
so
you know you take this an essential
service the ambulance one still baffles
me how we have to fundraise for that um
but you take it to where the helicopter
thing comes from
it's basically a airborne ambulance
um so
yeah i think it needs to come back i
hope it does come back they approach all
three tas for an annual plan
counselor evanson
thanks mr chair i guess um what brings
to my mind is um
we can't do everything we have to
prioritize and part of what we did when
we approved those recommendations around
the community well-being was actually
put some parameters on what we
what we wanted to prioritize to fund and
what we couldn't because it's not our
job to fund everything we don't have
enough money to do that
if you ask the government we don't even
have enough money to look after our own
infrastructure properly
so to my mind this is just not something
that's within our remit of things that
we should be prioritizing
we did the same thing during the long
term plan when we said
you know we're going to leave the water
tower for now
because we we can't do everything we
have to prioritize so i'm quite happy to
support the recommendation in this case
because i don't believe this is
something that should be a priority for
our council or local government
thank you
evelyn
oh cure mr chair
this is something that
council is then getting into doing
something that is actually the purview
of the health sector or the emergency
service response sector not the council
as such i know you're doing it on behalf
of
citizens
and
if if we agreed to do it we would be
doing it on behalf of citizens excuse me
however i don't think that that is what
citizens elect councillors to do is to
run an emergency response service
i think that
passing it on to the long-term plan
process is probably misleading them as
to what the opportunity for funding from
this council might be
in terms of
environment southland and its broader
overview i'm not sure exactly where it
sits with them either
but
that's the issue not ours
i just really think that we have got to
be really careful
that we don't start replicating or
picking up the tab for services that
actually
fit more
uh
adequately with other agencies and that
by default we're being asked to pay
thank you
thank you
anyone else
counselor scout
hello
do you cheer just if we're going to wait
for the health department or the central
government it's going to be a very long
wait
a hugely long wait
if the current regime continues the way
it is with our health service if we
don't value people that's fine
and we value bricks and mortar that's
fantastic but this is about people this
is actually about people
and saving lives of people but if we
don't have any credits around that
it's fine as a council
it's a bit shitty but but yeah i'll come
to you in a second counselor it's a it's
a bit sharp counsellor um may be but
true i'm not finished
we could take the money from other funds
that are bricks and mortar
to to to say that decision doesn't value
lives is actually tremendously unfair
that's your point of view
it's emotive
that's your point of view i'm entitled
to my point of view and i value people
over brooks and mordo mr chair
yep well i'm cheering the meeting
thank you councillor arnold
well i'm against the motion as you're
putting it as well because i also
believe that
there may be other opportunities and
other possible funding avenues for this
but at the moment there's not
uh there's no one really coming forward
and i think it wouldn't hurt for us to
take leadership on this i mean you've
got the
well-being fund and i don't see anything
that's better than well-being and the
fact the matter is that those other
uh funders or the health boards they
don't do this so i i believe that we
should it wouldn't hurt for us to take a
lead in this
and perhaps use that fund for this
because
the the money should be there and then
perhaps going forward put it as part of
the long-term plan
so as you put the
recommendation of everybody against it
okay thank you
other speakers
counselor cricket
sorry we're not getting your counsellor
are
um i genuinely take exception to the
fact that um one of our councillors has
stated that
uh us voting for the motion and not to
fund this
is a voter against us caring for people
because ultimately that's what everybody
around here at this table is here for
it is absolutely
uh demonstrative what our
responsibilities are and what our core
business is under the local government
act we're not a house or a emergency
fund provider and we're not pervaded to
do that under the local government act
it's simply out of scope
and it isn't
an effective use of rate payer money for
that for that cause
in my opinion of course you're very
entitled to your own but i reject the
fact that you're stating that we don't
care about people by doing by not voting
for it
how practically yeah
thank you
that's my two cents
counselors i'm going to take a vote now
and that will be by show of hands
so just so that we are clear the motion
is that the uh
option to fund
the lakes district air rescue trust is
declined
so if you support the motion if you
could raise your hand now please can we
just see sorry i just wanted to sorry
point of order i just wanted to see the
motion in writing sorry
there you go
so that's that's the motion that was put
forward right
you know you just had the other motion
up there at the time sorry cool thank
you
so all those in favor again if you could
raise your hand please just keep it up
there while we do account
three
four five six seven
and counselor crack at eight
it's a vote of eight so the motion is
carried
the issue is not closed and i think
councillors for the passion with which
they've spoken
the opportunity to raise the issue comes
up again through the annual plan or even
the unexplored option of raging raising
it with the regional council as it's
funded in uh by in dunedin
and you know i think there's many of us
that would step forward and advocate for
that to happen
uh in that place again recognizing the
value that we place on the service
bearing in mind that we've just taken
the vote councillor abbott
i'm wondering what it is you have to say
thank you anybody else which they vote
recorded against councillor arnold yes
councillor scout councillor clark
so can i just clarify chair that the
vote was eight seven in favor of the
motion
eight
we didn't take it thank you
i have four against did anybody else
vote against
did anybody abstain
yeah i'm listing an abstention i i think
there's more to be done councillor
partner and his worship have both
abstained from voting
eight five
comfortable with that
well comfortable is the best term i can
come up with at the moment
again uh thank you for your opinions and
for the debate
uh we move now to the great south letter
of expectation
rhiannon oh sorry mr chairman just note
that um i'm a director of great south
school council
thank you noted
thank you chair so this report outlines
the
great south litter of expectation and
statement of intent process that is a
process that happens annually
um
so the report lays out the time frame
and it includes recommendations for
council to consider around the
priorities
to be set for
great south and around the breakdown of
the funding
so
following
your discussion today
your recommendations and the text from
this report
which may be amended following your
discussion will be sent
to um
great south in a letter by the mayoral
forum so they will receive everyone's
feedback together
thank you can i ask following a
presentation recently from great south
was mentioned
around potential support for
an eyesight that's not covered in this
is it
no
um so what they've indicated is they may
respond at the time of statement of
intent with some additional options that
councils may wish to consider at that
time thank you
councillors there are three
recommendations they're looking for a
mover and a second first of all i'll
leave that
council apart and check council amundsen
it's open for discussion end or comment
counselor partner yeah um this covers
exactly what we talked about uh in that
workshop and i think it's nailed it so
yeah
i guess one of the things that the
workshop recognized is it was
there were works in progress that were
interrupted by covert
uh there's still
work around housing that were yet to see
some
resolution and recommendation from but
again the interruption of the business
hasn't hasn't helped with that
so it's been moved and seconded i'll put
the motion all in favor
against
carried
and finally and open the activity
reports
the move that the
report is received if there's a seconder
councillor lewis thank you any questions
or comments counselors
again interesting to see that you know
activities particularly around the
library and and splash palace
uh affected by by lockdowns and
restrictions on numbers that have been
able to attend
but also recognising that these business
arms were very nimble and quick to react
of course they didn't have much choice
and seeking
clarity around the changing landscape of
how many people you can have and what
you do
has
has been
a uh a challenge that they've met well
uh and despite all that they've actually
been some very groovy things going on at
the library i noted
however there are no other questions or
comments that's yes councillor scott
just steve just to wonder how um you and
your staff have felt around the
communications coming out of
um the level changes and so on for your
venues
have they been clear the clarity has
been clear
it's a very good question councillor
scott through you mr chair um
look i think most people are dealing
with responding to the evolving
situation
and in certain areas our pools
and our venues and door venues in
particular there have been some
quite tough requirements and whilst
we're managing to try and deliver a
service for the community
at the same time as responding to the
elite level requirements there have been
some challenges
but really proud of the team and i think
that's evidence by the way that in
particular in the civic the way that the
dhb and our council staff work together
to turn our vaccination clinic around
within 24 hours to keep providing
vaccinations for our communities
a good good response and that's
symptomatic of a lot of council staff
working with what we're given and then
applying the management now to make sure
that our community can access the
services and a safe doing so
in a roundabout way i guess what he's
saying and you'll appreciate it being in
the uh
and the venues business is that they've
done their best to operate in a vacuum
of information at times which has not
been
useful but i think they've performed
well
and just steve justin
from the point of care just the staff
well-being mental health of they're all
without going to any depth
in general terms across the venues and
so on they're all coping well
look it is
one of the things that through our alert
level plans that we
have instigated
regular workshop or toolbox talks
where we're not only checking in on how
we're following our levels but we're
also checking in on each other and so
across the board at the heiwo couturio
at the civic you know
facilities facilities that's a regular
um daily occurrence if not
two or three times a day with the
changeover of shifts so i'm pretty happy
with the way our team are checking in
it's not to say there aren't issues but
we're certainly trying to deal with them
with our teams
thank you
councillor clark yeah just steve um
in relation to um library splash palace
and some other venues that we may open
up as we get further towards the end of
the year
you've heard the government say
they may introduce vaccination
passports for people to come in and say
no jabs you don't come in
what will the city council approach be
to staff that are actually in those
premises will they be required to also
be vaccinated
come early december or will it be a
different approach
mr chair given it's a staffing matter i
think the easiest way in which i could
answer that is that the council will
follow the requirements set out by
government
so you're not teachers and you're not
health workers we're not teachers and
we're not health workers
uh i am very mindful that the
requirements the government has and the
reasons for introducing those
requirements could well extend
to uh many of the staff that we employ
but i would prefer not to be on the
front page of the south end times
being a
trendsetter i think we will follow the
requirements
that they set out for us as they work
through their own processes
thank
you any other questions or comments
thank you
yes yes
i'm just thinking about it and i don't
want to be on the front page either but
i do but
well
i do think it's it's relevant for as a
proactive council that if we are asking
the community to be safe when they come
to
venues that we manage that we should be
on the front foot
and encouraging at least
uh frontline staff to be also vaccinated
uh counsellor there is a world of
difference between encouragement and
requirement yes i think emily pankhurst
might have pointed that one out and the
position hasn't really changed so we'll
stick with the encouragement and we'll
wait until we're required
in fact we would encourage everybody
but i am concerned and it's no joke from
me i am concerned that the calls of
encouragement to get vaccinated are so
many that they could get lost
a message could get lost
and i guess it also it strikes a point
where
you know people are getting
passionate and vociferous and and and i
understand that
but sometimes that doesn't help for
people who are on the cusp and if i if i
cast my mind back to my personal
position when i enjoyed the pleasure of
smoking cigarettes oh god back then the
days when i had money
um
i and i knew it was bad for me and i had
100 people telling me that i should stop
but that just encouraged me to dig my
toes in until i made a rational decision
and gave it up mr chair you have
highlighted that there are people and we
have them on staff
who are unable to be vaccinated for
medical reasons and we just have to be
really careful there was somebody
reported to me yesterday as being an
anti-vaxxer and in fact it was on the
basis of a severe negative reaction to
something previous that they'd been
advised not to get the jab
um i'm not sure there's anything
attractive about being encouraged to get
a jab
um but
we just need to be mindful that people
do have different states of health in a
whole variety of ways
i've gone from being a 20 a day smoker
to a five a day jabber
it's not often i get to joke about
diabetes
any other uh comments or queries around
the activities report
look i would just conclude by um
by assuring councillor clark and all
councillors that we are watching the
space
emt discussed it as early as this
morning or as recently as this morning
so we are watching this
i guess i guess our obligation may be
beyond what's set by government i guess
if the government says
we're not going to force issue no jobs
no jobs
and that may will be the case i guess we
would have an immoral obligation if
people were coming to one of our
high intensity venues to say not all our
staff
are vaccinated
i um
i mean that gives the community some
choices as well we'll take advice at the
time yeah sure i think there's a matter
in here that i've been advised about
relating to proportionality okay so uh
we'll just wait and see
because the same will work in reverse
for those people wanting to go to venues
being asked whether they've been
vaccinated or not so but could we be
very clear that there is no point in
introducing things that we have no
ability to monitor or enforce
and that is also a bit of a challenge so
the idea of no jabs no getting into a
venue may well come down to an honesty
system rather than a regulatory system
and i'm not looking for an extension of
regulatory powers
councilor bottinger
thank you aren't we looking at that for
three waters
um
no local government
no three waters report
i wonder where the vaccination was uh
coming in at that point
it's been moved and seconded so i'm now
going to put the motion all those in
favor of receiving the report say aye
against carried before we go into public
excluded and i'll go into that
process in in just a moment
can i just um
offer a note of support to our
monophenol representatives and welcome
you to the joys
of uh public consultation and
submissions
and that often
people have views
about council
that we've all had to endure in the past
and
i'm sorry that at the first meeting
you've had to experience some of that
but may i commend you on the
the dignity of your silence
i'll move that we go into public
excluded to discuss the receiving of the
pe minutes of the community well-being
fund from august 26 for reason
under section 721
and also consultation options for icl
similarly under section 721 mr chair
just before you do that
the report for consultation options was
circulated late so it should be received
as a major late item uh so before i go
to that i'll move that we receive it as
a much later item seconded councillor
pottinger all in favor
aye against
carrie thank you and now uh secondly
with the exception of mr grant and mr
mckenzie noted
put that motion all in favor
hi against carried for those that have
been joining us on the live stream thank
you
we'll now pause while we go into public
excluded
you